Let's take a close look at how
food technology helps us and
technology such as
flash pasteurization improves the shelf life
of our food while
protecting it from harmful bacteria.
Food technology allows us to
replace the air inside food packaging.
to preserve its natural flavor,
color and texture
and supplemental antioxidants
guarantee the last conservation of
food for the maximum time possible
while avoiding its deterioration and preserving
its best qualities
in our homes we can
enjoy modern ecological refrigerators that, in
addition to keeping food fresh
and  crisps use much less
energy in the process
in short food technology
allows us to avoid this and preserve this
food technology in europe meets
the most stringent control standards to
protect our health keep our
food fresh and tasty and
strengthen our  stra economy
food technology food with the best
quality